hey guys i'm new students joined here by
rob crossley we're here at gamescom 2015
today we have both been hands-on with
Mirror's Edge catalyst yeah i mean is i
came away thinking oh my goodness this
is just an incredible game I've got a
lot of hype for this game already okay
yes I start with the the first mission
that we played was kind of campaign
mission to get you started on on the
free running mechanics so faith in
prison and its have released a bit
you're presented with the entire city
and you choose a waypoint and the
amazing thing is that they'll then do
like a path for you it's like sat nav
for parkour basically so you run its but
open well so you run to your mission and
the first mission happens to be a race
it's a race so it's really getting new
acquainted with the the park or so it's
actually very simple to get to grips
with it some left bumper to go up yep
I'm left trigger to go down so left
bumper to jump and left trigger to slide
under things and also when you when you
land on something to roll I didn't do
that but I was really impressed with
that I know it sounds I mean the thing
is it the simplicity of it was amazing
going through the landscape in such such
an easy and free flowing way I thought
that was really impressive from there we
went into I it was kind of again a
momentum building one but had come back
any given a route to follow and they're
just God's fit along the way yeah uh you
know gradually they get tougher like one
guy had a gun like just trying to just
the flow combat was quite nice oh yeah i
mean i think i love how everything is
now based on momentum so if you're
sprinting towards someone and you press
the x button you'll barge into them and
they will be flattens or if your flight
if you're falling through the air and
you press the attack button you will
jump on them and take them out
completely but if you have no momentum
so you're just standing next to them and
you press attack they get the better of
you and i love how you have to admit
their full use momentum have to use
speed you have to use your agility in
order to get over these people that was
really cool and the part
played was a it was built this thing
about a billboard mission while you're
basically taking down the propaganda in
the city of glass yeah but you have to
climb this bill bought our a certain way
or find a route and then when you get
there you can remove the negative
propaganda and put up some of your honor
yeah so this was basically the mastery
of your traversal skills right you had
to do it very quickly you had to think
on your feet very quickly and yeah you
had to go out quite some big Heights
didn't use so that was really impressive
as well but you saw an extended demo
this morning that I didn't get a chance
to see what was in it ok so the extended
demo touched a bit more on the story but
the great thing was like we saw the
interiors as well and if you remember
the interiors in the original mirrors
edge but they were like these beautiful
future s romanticized like Kia buildings
weren't they they were strange but like
kind of cool they have the same thing
and it just it was just really awesome
to like move around them they also have
like environmental puzzles now as well
informed a little bit by portal is my
suspicions so suddenly you're in a room
you're trying to figure out how to get
out of the room and you have to look at
the environment and figure out how to do
it and and you know and I thought that
was a really nice touch that's cool so
both very positive impressions or
burma's at catalyst out early next year
februari yeah yeah more meritage to
Annika's gamescom 2015 and make sure you
stay tuned to gamespot com
you